[Music]
I think I think this works
yeah absolutely
I'll be better back yeah I'll try to be
very passive aggressive in the beginning
just to stress them out
I think we should say all this [ __ ] this
was
yeah
and they and I hate [ __ ] podcasts as
they know I know it's so let's save that
all I'm coming up and I was like you
know we should do it next week Alex he's
like no no no tomorrow and I'm like Mark
then when I get here Matt's going almost
coming from South Africa but his
honeymoon I was like what is this is
this is this filming right now okay
we're using all of this why are we doing
today Mark's coming back from [ __ ]
South Africa I said next week I ran into
Sam in the street first of all I thought
it was on a University Place which is
where a guy like you should be doing a
podcast yeah not in the middle of the
[ __ ] I saw you on the street the
other day trying to get rid of the
goddamn Heritage but was stuck here in
garmento you know the garmento said
it was a garmento it's a garment
district isn't it but they just call
them commentos
you heard that phrase garmentos no I'm
really about to be gone from New York I
think it was a famous thing in the 70s
all the Jewish eat lunch in 20 minutes
all these guys Bill Bill Chef you know
Bill Chef the comic yeah yeah he used to
do a routine about garmentos at lunch
which was one of the funniest bits of
all time he goes this is how different
in today's one the bit was his every
comment though at lunch a guy from
Westchester ordering in his favorite
restaurant uh sweetheart cookie cookie
no not him me I was next not him to
bring me toast bring me it was it was
burnt I'm not gonna if it's undercooked
you know what actually bring me the
order and then I'll tell you what's
wrong with it then you just tell the
chef tell the cook it's for Mr fine and
he's just this great character a little
character bit Yeah and but anyway
comment a little bit like remember Bobby
Collins at the seller every he always
calls he doesn't know anyone's names
because all the guys handsome and all
the women gorgeous yes hey you're
handsome I'm like well I guess I guess
I've put myself together today someone
else has done handsome how are you he's
like a homeless guy hey handsome
oh man this whole neighborhood was go
it's still a little bit of it a little
Garmin Center guys that you know and it
was mob run of course the mob because
they had the trucks so the trucks don't
move they gotta go to Chinatown to the
sweatshops and then out to you know
whatever gimbals or whatever stores will
you know Marshalls out in Long Island
and Jersey so they really had a
Stranglehold on this whole area those
two gambinos The Gambino family and then
the guys that ran it I worked at a
restaurant with a these the guys that
own this particular business in game you
know I think Joe Gambino and Tom again
they were the owners they'd come in like
once a month that like the owners are
coming today and like real gentlemen
like you wouldn't say their name but but
they come in you could not see two guys
less mob like they were just these tall
thin like Patrician looking guys and
they were like the like the campaign man
they half the guys they were like
crazier than them you know were they
polite no they didn't talk to me they
were kind of dicks actually but I say
that now of course they're dead there's
a lot of it you know what they were had
a lot on their mind
yeah they're just like by the way Norman
is running late that's why right now he
will be here but Mark uh with I didn't
even know it was going to be an issue
that he I woke up today with a text from
Mark saying uh my flight's delayed I'm
like delayed you were supposed to get in
a day ago so Mark's coming in from South
Africa from South Africa everybody
we schedule this even if
there wasn't a delay why would you and I
blame you and Matt who had just met and
Mark Norman to schedule a thing a time
sensitive thing on a day somebody's
coming back from South Africa that's not
intelligent I blame Mark Norman because
I didn't know that this was even an
issue and he was so excited you were on
I'll be like I'll be gonna ignore
McDonald you didn't know South Africa
was an issue
you know you believe anyway that's what
normal do you'd be like no no I didn't
mean like that you're racist you believe
South Africa no no I didn't mean it like
that he uh no he just texted me this
morning you know I'm delayed I'm like
what the [ __ ] are you and of course it's
on the news he's it's Pete bootage Edge
is like we're working on it I'm like I
know this is our pie this [ __ ] up our
podcast yes booty just doesn't
understand that even though it's a
computer failure there's nothing to do
with him we're all gonna blame him yeah
this is his legacy unless he because he
looks like he's powered by a computer he
looks like a yeah he does he was built
in a lab he was yeah he was built by
zielinski no evidence of a Cyber attack
but also won't rule it out yeah
would they admit if it was a Cyber
attack I know it makes us look like
[ __ ] I know
the airlines suck and also Mark flew
United you never fly United that's
[ __ ] amateur hour you never go full
United no
no well let's get Morgan the phone and
just look can we get him on the phone
real quick all right let's do it let me
call him
he's gonna he's gonna be furious right
now well he's he's never faced the fury
I'm gonna have uh-oh I'm excited for
this
let's see what we got mark
I'm gonna should we pretend you better
tell him he's on a podcast so what's up
to you
yeah
it's way too casual
[Laughter]
here
24 hours
Colin's pissed dude yeah
you know what what the final nail of the
coffin
Jerry was right about you you're
unprofessional wow
he said Jerry was right about you you're
not professional
[Music]
well I'll be he's bad cop I'm good cop
because I do I do feel bad that you
24-hour delay is insane a 24-hour delay
travel day 16-hour flight coach
divorce territory here she's Furious I
left her at the airport she's in the bag
you know what that was my advice and
Colin said that I was crazy I was about
to float that you should leave oh my God
your wife at the airport on your
honeymoon oh my God
I did it do you know how much it's gonna
cost you
yeah you're in the [ __ ] are you in the
doghouse
[Music]
no
later in 2028
. you uh you left your wife at the
honeymoon she's gonna she'll forgive you
when your first kid graduates College
that's my prediction
you Asian books your flights
uh manager yeah man yeah you gotta you
gotta not go through DC
this whole plan is terrible [ __ ] I'm
greasy
who's on the flight
what 7 A.M
[Music]
10 a.m
in DC Lounge you know what I'll do a
bodega cat solidarity pour into my
coffee for you
thank you but I'll be there in 20
minutes if you can hang out and we're
hanging tell them to [ __ ] we don't
believe 20. we yeah we don't believe 20
but but I will be here tell them to hit
every hit the gas no
hit the gas
he said we're going to talk about your
gay Italian movies we want Colin Quinn
movie racks this episode
all right and uh yeah dude
is that Monday because I'm going the
same night
I believe it is it's opening night oh
yeah opening night over here all right
by the way Colin Quinn's new show small
talk
at the at the Cherry Lane theater
no Lucille latel Lucille close if you go
to the Cherry Lane it's only two blocks
walk away so you won't be you'll be able
to figure it out yeah
uh all right I'll be there uh opening
night I can't wait I've seen bits and
pieces and it's already it's all coming
together it's all coming together
best power yet that's unfortunately was
produced by United but uh oh
all right
I wouldn't pull that yet uh Mark Collins
he's not having it today having what
otherwise
it was in bad moods I'm gonna have to
keep the good energy you really screwed
us
you're in pajamas I love it I can't
believe oh God
the field to begin from flying yeah I'm
sorry buddy
bad travel day
all right your wife's gonna burn your
clothes when she gets her bags back
this is the beginning this is I I'm look
just don't make the next wedding uh
destination and I'll be there come on
all right thank you I'll see you soon
White Plains New York
on 911 get a discount
like Gary veter he got married on 911 so
we got the discount yeah oh my God
[Laughter]
soon all right
all right I'll see you mark
uh Mark's not uh good over the phone
yeah he's not he doesn't he's not a
phone he only called me one Marcus only
called me on the phone maybe twice which
is crazy in all the years of friendship
he's a texter he doesn't like to be tied
down that seems like he seems like that
kind of guy that made him uncomfortable
even and I noticed uh he called me once
if I get a phone call from Mark I know
something horrible just happened the
other time he called me
I don't even know I should tell this
story but I kind of have to now
Sherrod small choked him out after a set
of the cellar yeah that's old news yeah
all right I don't know if it's podcast
news is it podcast 12 year old news yeah
well let me call you well yeah but he's
gonna call he's a tax guy and he was
like what do I do about Sharad and I was
like fix it I don't [ __ ] know keep
the beef going for 12 years that's a
good idea
well he likes to text another one with
that unless you want to do a podcast
then it's probably something wrong with
that he's great on on mics he's bad on
phones
I don't know what that is but
shouldn't Dan be doing that the hell are
you doing I mean I was just gonna pour
some of my coffee a little Bodega cat
whiskey
I forgot all about that yeah it's our
whiskey man
hey it's kind of a cool name it is kind
of yeah I appreciate it I don't know I
don't want to give it up but I will give
it up how do you feel how do you feel
about all the 7-Elevens in the city is
that oh it makes me sick yeah but it's
still I'm so used to this it started in
94. in 94. I came back to New York I was
in LA for a couple years I moved back to
New York and I was on Coney Island which
is really the heart of Brooklyn you know
and especially back then this is almost
30 years ago and there was a Domino's
Pizza
and I was like it's over I know I get
mad when I see dominoes in New York this
1994. WOW in the heart of Brooklyn I
mean like Coney Island Avenue is deep in
you know yeah
yeah when that when that one right
around the corner from Stand Up New York
went down I think as it was like a
Marshalls now yeah that was [ __ ]
pretty that was good that was a good
pizza it was a good pizza I agree with
you Pizza New York it was an underrated
Pizza well even like mediocre New York
Pizza is better than [ __ ] Domino's uh
yeah but Domino's is terrible no I feel
like when new when New York Pizza sucks
it's bad yeah there's a million places
bad pizzas this neighborhood right here
some of the worst Pizza in the world
well not not all of it oh Joe's is great
but I'm saying
the dollar slices around the corner
terrible they're terrible it's just all
salt and crab you're against the beard
you I'm the horrible I work around here
and those are the only places open when
I get out of work so it's just it's
awful just like cardboard well I'll tell
you what's good but it's on 9th Avenue
and 53rd so it's a little 51st what's it
called
it's been there for 100 years that's a
good slice but you're not gonna work all
the way up there
um what are your go-to slices in the
city besides
I don't know I mean Ben's isn't bad
Ben's the Grandma's good Ben's is it's
killed by association it's two geography
killed Benz remember your great rep they
price gouge during Hurricane Irene and
I'll [ __ ] never forget it that was a
dick move it was 60 for a pie wow it's a
blackout you guys have a generator
people are hungry yeah so I go there
less I feel like I feel like because it
was in Louie's intro people would go in
there it was like a tourist thing for a
while oh Ben's right right yeah
yeah I like this setup and I like the
fact that it's it's not bad yeah it's
not bad but Joe's is [ __ ] good I know
and the truth is New Haven really does
have the best pizza isn't that annoying
they [ __ ] do they really do Pepe's
it's your best it's the best pizza
Sally's and the other modern pizza I
haven't had that one they're all good
yeah I haven't had mine but I just said
it because I think yeah nobody will know
I'll be gonna know I didn't have it
we uh we were pumped to talk movies with
you because you're like let's talk move
well you're like an OG movie guy you're
like you know I feel like you know so
much about movies I I was just watching
YouTube Criterion closet yes and you're
in the Criterion closet which is a
[ __ ] honor to be in there
you know well I don't know about that
but I mean I think it's pretty cool it
is cool I would call it an honor
um I would say it was cool but I mean uh
but yeah the Criterion closet was good
and I really did surprise myself I have
to say you know you know because of your
lady [ __ ] everything but remember I
told the story of that lady in there
which one was that this old Iranian lady
or I don't know if she was Iran but she
was from somewhere around there but she
uh she was a video store clerk back when
they had video stores and I on 57th
Street I was on 56 and then she would go
uh this movie is good and every time I
went in she would give me something I
never heard of
and every time I was like what this is
the greatest color of paradise an
Iranian movie does she give you the king
of masks a Chinese movie then she give
you a movie from a Yugoslavia then
moving from any place every damn every
day and she was never wrong she had the
best taste but she she died because she
was sick even then I could tell she died
of cancer but she never there was not
one movie I saw I was like God that was
that was that's like an indie movie
right there as you going in for the yes
for the wreck and you could tell she's
dying Tarantino of New York you know
dude I used to I like that the movie
store you go you talk movies yeah that
was a New York energy thing I remember
Kim's video it's small talk that's what
it's all about yeah my show's about
because that is a New York energy thing
and I feel like it's energy anyway I
feel like down south you used to like
the small to all these places yeah King
video of course I loved it yeah it was
classic and I want to say more that one
that was Kim's right well that was Kim's
yeah yeah that was yeah of course that
was great that was like they had all the
Indie [ __ ] and uh yes I used to go run
on runs over there uh to get stuff I was
at Colbert I would get them like movies
from there there was the ones were
always to go there
they had all the they had all the cool
movies they had so all cool movies I
missed those like the person behind the
desk was like cool they were like cooler
than you
I like that and then they were cooler
they were the biggest nerds I've ever
seen yeah movie wise they were much
cooler in that world they were cool yes
but I was watching and you turned me
onto a movie Mona Lisa with Bob Haas oh
the best that's a great [ __ ] movie
great movie I don't know if I wrecked it
I wreck it on the Pod I did because of
Colin that movie's amazing yeah Bob
Hoskins Kathy Tyson that movie's a
Michael Caine is in that yeah I went on
a Bob Hoskins kick uh because of that
watch I just watched Who Framed Roger
Rabbit right after it he's [ __ ] great
in them well good Friday I haven't seen
that is that good is that that's Bob
Hoskins that's that's the next to Mona
Lisa that's the best
he's looking great man Logan Friday is
amazing all right you've watched sexy
beast yeah it's a great movie yeah
Barry's favorite movies it's sexy every
time I saw Todd Berry you watched sexy
beast yeah yeah because Todd Barry wants
to be the Ben Kingsley of that movie he
wants to be a bold badass he wants to be
the more badass that comes in and just
like starts threatening us and curse
against the forcing us to do whatever he
wants us to do I don't know whatever
sexy beast is [ __ ] cool so I'll see
this is great chance as hell Kingsley
scary as [ __ ] yes that's a great movie
what are some other common sleepers
longer Friday is definitely one all
right that should not be you know what I
mean
um from England there's a movie called
Easter's East which Keith Robinson hates
so I start by putting that in there
there's a movie called ladybird you ever
see Lady Bird the recent one not a girl
this is from like 1998 it's called
ladybird ladybird all right from 1996 or
something amazing there's a movie called
nil by mouth so nil by mouth you know
what the guy insectivity is Ray Winstone
right yeah yeah he's in this movie Now
by mouth Gary Oldman wrote it and it's
all kind of autobiographical about Gary
Owen grew up in the you know the
projects whatever they're called in
England you know and your stepfather was
a brute and so it's it's his personal
thing it's unbelievable
Ray Winstone you want to kill him he's
the most evil guy in this movie it's a
amazing you're not even watching a movie
you're like I gotta get out of this
house you're like oh wait I'm gonna
watch a movie it's like one of those
same with ladybird ladybird you stressed
me out because I told you to watch a
movie that's like an old New York movie
and you call me back Mikey and Nikki
yeah Elaine and Colin calls me after 25
minutes and was like this is the biggest
piece of [ __ ] I've ever seen and I was
stressed I was like I just I made Colin
mad then you call me like an hour later
you're like all right it was pretty good
yeah it definitely got better it
definitely got better I just thought it
was weird and slow like if I see like an
old New York movie that's like kind of
got grit to it I just think of you I
know I do like those I do love them
oh my did he get here early holy [ __ ]
I'm here you made it we thought you were
gone for another 10 minutes we've been
rolling because we're waiting yeah you
must be burned I'm dead am I in your
seat here I'm jet lagged I lost my
luggage I'm gay I'm all over the place
I was in South Africa this is crazy
today yesterday I actually went to South
Africa and I flew coach so I know all
right
it's like 25 years it took you so long
to get married was that no that's uh
she's Furious but that's either here nor
there
I came in I said why didn't you just
leave her the airport immediately Khan
goes oh you out of your [ __ ] mind
yeah you know I guess the single guy
shouldn't be given that was a bad advice
wow I had to do the Pod but but uh I got
a show to promote you know I was gonna
tell him this Jim Norton story oh please
about the airport so we did a tour of
Iraq like 2004. so it's me Norton loika
Martin and my assistant I think Ellen
and um so we come back all right
so we
get weeks bonding going over like
they're shooting you know what I mean
like we had a couple of yeah we get back
you'd have the plane from Iraq
and we go to get our bags and Norton
goes over there I see him walking
towards the exit so I'm like that's
funny he's pretending to just not say
goodbye uh he gets into Camp leaves so I
go that's even funnier he's pretending I
call him later I go hey what the [ __ ] he
goes oh [ __ ] man I'm sorry I go you
sociopath you literally didn't say
he literally didn't say goodbye to us
because he's like ah the Trip's over
wow playing in these was I mean we're
having body moments with the troop and
this bastard and then he goes I'm sorry
I go to the plane I made an appointment
with a hooker
every time I was afraid it's gonna be
late
and he acted like that was the one right
All Is Forgiven correct
person you think it was a hooker that
should be a card yes thank you I had to
leave the hooker Hallmark yeah he was on
trans before anybody by the way this is
where he beat like it's like it comes
around he was ahead of the game yeah he
was ahead of the game by far but that
doesn't explain but the point is that
pissed me off when Norton did it yeah it
really it really pissed me off in many
ways
imagine how his wife is going to feel oh
yes yeah well he's going to see a hooker
right after this that's pretty bad it's
gonna cost you hell yeah no I I the fact
that I said you should do it and Colin
immediately was like are you [ __ ]
dumb oh yeah oh yeah I guess you
shouldn't leave your wife at the airport
for a podcast after a honeymoon yeah
it's a bad day yeah well we're welcome
to reality sister this is what it's like
but I mean this is big for you to take a
vacation though that's true and you know
International thank you sir I don't even
know what that is but I'm excited to
drink it but I gave it 30 minutes I
waited for the bag for 30 minutes and
nothing so I was like I gotta go I mean
I'm I would have been there by now I
would have been on time but uh I stayed
I could have broken my wife and did you
wait for the bag for 30 minutes and you
know and my wife
did you give it did you give it the old
are you cool with this I did I did and I
I was texting I was like I'm on the
phone with United right now I was
snoozing in the back seat but how was
she like she go yeah it's fine and give
you the look in her eyes like it's not
fine I don't look her in the eye
but yeah we were talking it's gonna be
ugly you're not good on the phone you're
a great podcaster well I was Furious I
was Furious but you're not a phone
person in general not really not really
I'm not a huge certain people I call on
the phone yeah yeah I don't mind a phone
call I'm not one of these uh [ __ ] the
phone guys but I was a young guy that
was a mood you guys would text me it's a
whole generational thing a lot of voice
memo people you guys yeah
because it was like hey what's up um and
then you listen to that [ __ ] [ __ ]
right right I'm gonna start leaving
voice members of all those people and
see how they like it yeah you might be
good at it that's true I don't want to
be good I want to annoy people
you can do cameo
um
I'll never do Cameo they keep they keep
bugging me me too and I'm like no
because I'll say some horrible [ __ ] and
then it'll go online and then you're
[ __ ]
I can't imagine doing camera first of
all I usually I'm shocked by Cameo not
the idea of selling myself for money but
the idea that the money is so low
well you can well you can make yeah you
can make no some people you're like 800
for Emma Smith like maybe a 1998. come
on yeah really 800 no certain people I
mean it's like 60 bucks 80 no let's not
do it because it's gonna humiliate our
friends
um look at our friends we can look at
just regular jerkers all right let's
look at yeah get like Eric Estrada I bet
he's uh I bet he's 60. I bet he's 16 out
yes go to like athletes
it's probably a high price how much
Woody Allen
Wow Snoop Dogg yeah that's got to be in
the like the 50 Grands or so it's gotta
be 50 Grand we have a special relation
with Mark that's a long story you do no
we but we found a video of him just
screaming he's a hot head 90 yeah he was
just screaming at a fan yeah he called
him sugar gay instead of Sugar Ray
like 20 minutes on the kid can you blame
him I'll kick your [ __ ] ass but guess
what he's been trying to be nice this
whole time people call him whatever you
know all right let's see what the money
is first all right what do we got here
300 Lewis and guess what you better pay
up
guaranteed nobody sniffs him that Cameo
slaps yeah oh yeah
I was thinking of the murderer
I'm old
Ray Lewis that's right
um
Ray Lewis in the news where the hell is
it football I think it's just
entertaining for the fans bad radio oh
wow okay 330. Lewis and then 50 for Dave
weinstep coach okay
all right it's a fun thing this is just
too cheap we're kind of scraping the
bear 73. some people my friend did and
he just donated all to charity which I'm
like oh that's something that's not bad
but if you think about it as dinner you
go hey give me 100 bucks and you go out
to dinner
pretty good I think Mark's talking
himself into Cameo maybe I am I think so
maybe I am you know I've noticed it
helps a lot of those like uh like
Instagram people who do skits with like
voices oh yeah they clean up and they're
like small time but on Cameo they clean
up it's like 30 50 bucks a pop it's a 15
second video you do 20 a day what if I
wish you a happy birthday
20 a day
Owen Wilson exactly what did you open
was it okay here's the problem with
Cameo though sometimes you get like a
hay my son is dying of cancer can you do
a video and if you get used to Cameo you
start going well how much you gonna give
me dad you know I'm not gonna do this
for free right right I do the other ones
for 100 bucks yeah just because your
kids got cancer why does he get treated
pay up first then you get the leukemia
video okay yes he's gonna die anyway
yeah 15 Impressions it would be it would
be that's a different story yeah oh yeah
then you have to do them but then you've
got guys like Dan Soder who are
incredible Impressions but just don't do
them right right he just like keeps that
to himself yeah he just plays around
yeah give me Fred Stoller let's see how
he's doing there I guarantee if Fred
Stoller is on Cameo no way I'm telling
you I think Gilbert Godfrey cleaned up
on this [ __ ] oh yeah Affleck the the
wow I called it well he's cheap as [ __ ]
stole her you deserve more yeah I've
known him forever funny guy funny guy
funny guy
all right all right let's get up
hey folks this show is sponsored by
better help when you're on top of the
world you can do great things but if
life gets you bogged down and you can't
do anything you feel overwhelmed working
with a therapist makes you more prepared
to take on everything life throws at you
we love therapy we're in therapy highly
recommended get the garbage out it's
building up in your head you can't
Fester everybody's festered about
something I don't care who you are Kanye
or anybody else better help is
convenient flexible affordable entirely
online fill out a brief questionnaire
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge easy peasy tell them
how to do it if you want to live a more
empowered life Kanye therapists can get
you there visit betterhelp.com drunk
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash drunk
yes why are you still paying insane
amounts of money every month on your
phone bill you idiot right now when you
switch to Mint mobile you'll get their
unlimited plan for 50 off mint mobile
lets you order from home and save with
phone plans starting at just 15 a month
holy moly it's the perfect time to
switch but hurry because this deal and
said oh geez this still ends January 15
and through any three month plan and get
buy any three month plan and get three
more months free even on your Unlimited
Plan wow all plans come with unlimited
talk and text plus high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5G
Network love your current phone no
problem use your phone with any mint
Mobile plan and switch easily in five
minutes with e Sim
buy any three-month mint Mobile plan and
get three more months free by going to
mintmobile.com drunk that's
mintmobile.com
drunk cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com drunk hurry
offer ends January 15th hell yeah
he'll be missed
um look at
look at this I'm sick of looking at it
oh the passport oh yeah look at my uh my
photo I use this joke all the time I say
I look like an Albanian knife salesman
that's your joke for uh Anthony cumia in
one of the roads
I like that Louisiana USA you really do
look like a Louisiana like one of those
crazy uh swamp guys what do you make
Mark by the way yeah what is this oh so
this is kind of like we'll taste it
first and maybe I'll let you know
oh that's damn good so it's uh like a a
basil and
um Ruby oolong tea simple with uh
Aviation gin and a little cranberry
delightful what do you call it I'm
that's just it's a South African delay
United
I just made it up so you can call it
whatever you want yeah an Sab s-a-d
upset
I cannot believe you've been in South
Africa first I know it's crazy it
doesn't take time off neither do I but
wait but he has to now well how about
this buckle up there fatty because this
is quite a journey I did South Africa
this whole tour you got to do the
planning with the package do you want
the elephant package you want the
giraffe you want to shoot them whatever
you want so I go give me the 10-day
South African safari every day yeah
remote Lodge on the river in the jungle
yes I'll send you photos please wow look
at that well that's Cape Town
uh so boy I put too much filter on that
thing Jesus but uh so
yeah I go hey we're going to South
Africa but we have some extra time
before
let's go to Amsterdam do some drugs so
we go to Amsterdam for four days we did
shrooms we got high we we did the canals
and then we went from there to Cape Town
which is a 12-hour flight then from Cape
Town we went to the this title airport
called Suzuka and that's where you get
off and drive two hours into the jungle
and you go to your Lodge all right
what's the lodge like Lodge is
unbelievable unreal I gotta say I should
have seen these photos while I was in
the Uber but it's just crazy and every
day you get up at five you get a guide
he takes you out in a jeep with a
Tracker some African dude who sits on
the front of the Jeep and just goes hold
on and he stops he goes like this
and the car stops and then he goes and
you look you look over there and you see
like a giraffe or something and then you
get back in the car and whatever and you
see a line we saw a leopard we saw Rhino
it was pretty pretty amazing it did some
good things your trip was like too Colin
exactly the same yeah oh yeah
they would have breakfast it was all
inclusive I drank my face off so you'd
get up at five you go on this fire for
two hours you come back you have
breakfast you sit by the pool you drink
then you go again at 4 pm is that what
you did yeah without the drinking but
yeah
yeah and then uh then you come back from
that you eat dinner you drink more you
get to know all the other guests there's
people from Africa Australia Britain and
then you do it all over again the next
day and it's great you're gonna stay in
touch with any of the guests no God no
but uh nice people my dumb wife lets the
comedy thing out of the bag so then the
whole [ __ ] Trip's ruined oh my God
now you got every uh Tom Dick and Nigel
out there going hey mate tell us tell us
a quick one and you're like ah oh now
I'm doing Jew jokes in the middle of the
Jungle yeah well there's no way to hide
it yeah I tried because even when you go
oh I'm in entertainment they go what do
you do I know you just went up with
veteran on the road we're in the back of
an Uber though what do you guys do he
goes insurance salesman and he has like
a whole gag running for it and we're
just I'm just like just take the wheel
Gary [ __ ] perfect because No One's
Gonna no one no one is a follow-up
question yeah Insurance that's not true
every once in a while is very important
I know but he's got his little gag right
we're trying to [ __ ] in Hartford yeah
what do you you say everybody's got
something I said medical supplies no I
always say comedian because I know they
know they they recognize my voice
usually like what are you uh I thought
you were him right I don't know my name
but they know who I was do you do voice
over a lot or no no I'm terrible
voiceover are you when I started in
business everybody's like you got to do
voiceovers you'll be great and I went in
a couple of times and just it went
horribly
really at this point though everyone
knows your voice you should do
voiceovers turned down the voice over
and they hired a guy that sounded like
me and was like Hey That's you and that
[ __ ] Pizza commercial I'm so mad
about that ah that's the weird thing
about voice because I've gone into
people you got a weird voice you should
do this and then you go in and they go
take it take it take it from the top and
they go oh that was bad do another one
yep and I'm like I thought you liked my
voice which one is it yeah but I guess
you gotta have inflection or yeah no
there's something about it that some
people just are good at it some people
are good at it whatever they want who
gives a [ __ ] who can't I don't care what
these people want anyway it makes you
mad just I know like we like this they
go shut up right your products sell well
because of your stupid insights and I'm
the one with the voice I'm the one with
the jokes why do you matter thank God
for thank God for uh comedy is the only
thing where you can actually go look all
arguments to the side put you put us in
front of a crowd and then tell me how
you feel right exactly we always go all
over the country and have to kill right
they don't leave like a five mile radius
in Los Angeles and who it's some chick
behind a like a fold table folding table
going no I'm like who are you right the
hell do you know but they have jobs we
do have to we do do have to give you a
slice of Joe's before it gets yeah well
oh yeah please for acting they have a
point though I'm telling you right now
right now acting I should teach comedy
acting
you're a good actor dude
I'm a good actor I suck so badly I'm not
good I'm fine because I'm not but I was
so bad for years because I did all the
mistakes that a comedian would make I
would go into every situation like if we
were sitting here talking right now and
then acting scene and I would say I
better be interesting I better be funny
better be on yeah and guess what you
have to actors know you just either are
or aren't you don't [ __ ] try and when
you're on stage no no what about a
commercial why the hell would you want
with me when I'm not even done make life
points I've gone through so many years
I'll tell you the history of my acting
then you tell me all right well you've
been in four movies
I bet the bad side of it okay okay
Crocodile Dundee day once Night at the
Roxbury when I was on MTV and yes I
started conversation that way
in for a year and a half I want to tell
you they're like this guy we're gonna
make a show around him yeah one time
they flew me in from Kansas I was in the
middle of a gig at College gig in Kansas
in these days they didn't fly people in
like private jet oh yeah it's like the
90s early 90s and they go they want you
for this part that whoever was bailed
out the show's picked up uh it's 13
episodes it was a big Network comedy
kind of a cop comedy show oh I they fly
him in on a Sunday
fly me in La beautiful Suite like real
Beverly Hills type [ __ ] baby I go there
the next day NBC ABC who knows what was
one of those that one of the big Network
there's only four [ __ ] networks yes
so you're walking into luxury
everything's the top of the line all the
executives there about 15 Executives
lined up like this is it and they flew
me in they studied me beautiful girl
supposed to be that my sidekick we were
host a little bit
I mean I killed yeah I mean I'm talking
to them and I'm killing the room they're
like this is a guy I'm joking we start
reading I suck the energy out of the ah
because my acting was so bad because I
was trying and the girls looking at me
and I could feel it's just and I it was
gone but maybe the script was really bad
no it wasn't the script I'm telling you
they could have fixed it it was me it
was cheers dude because the show was
cheers so if I said with all these
acting teachers I couldn't really
understand it yeah instead of a few
people who were really great who really
showed me stuff but one of them was just
lady Sandra Lee this old lady and one
time I was in her class and I was still
trying to and we did this Arthur Miller
saying as me and the girl she gives the
girl notes and then she goes like this
for the whole glass to page she goes and
you
oh it starts imitating me but it was
great it really finally clicked that
moment I started laughing yeah oh yeah
I'm trying I'm acting you don't [ __ ]
try
you don't try they were saying you just
are is what you're saying yes ah I think
if if I'm trying to be it's like if
somebody goes on stage and does comedy
and then trying to be like funny yeah
it's [ __ ] sweaty same thing with
acting right you're funny if you're
doing a scene you don't have to you can
trust you don't have to do funny [ __ ]
yeah you're gonna be your natural
funniness comes through or it doesn't
you can't [ __ ] fix it by trying right
that's what I'm saying he's saying you
felt like you were a faker or something
yeah phony yeah I was being fake I'm
saying the point is trust that you're in
that comp doesn't that come from just
like practice I mean like anything no no
well yeah practice but but it also comes
from if you don't accept that you're
enough for people to watch you're dead
if you try to add on to yourself in the
scene yes you're exactly what I do but
there's every time I've never gotten one
audition I've auditioned 9 000 things
I've never got one so far
why would you argue when I'm serious
who I am giving you the [ __ ] answer
and like the typical comedian you're too
cocky but it's a little vague oh you
can't try what does that mean
s obtuse but it's not a little bit
but trees are the best audition advice
I've ever heard he said go in for the
party he's dressed as the thing you're
auditioning for I think that's pretty
good first of all that's [ __ ] what
amateur one-on-one
what about you don't try don't try what
is that I want to see Mark in a
policeman we found the dead body praise
Allah
I'd like yeah I want you to show up in a
mob movie in a pinstripe shooting hey
Bob De Niro Tommy Gun but wait a minute
don't try you go in you go uh they go
hey you know the lines you're going no
I'm not trying they can't do it you
don't know the lines I'm saying don't
try to entertain ah don't cry okay I'm
saying you go in there and if you're
supposed to be like if I'm talking to
somebody and the scene's supposed to be
funny and I mean Pizza I'm not gonna try
to be funny eating pizza right right I'm
eating pizza it'll be funny because I'm
whatever's going on in the scene yeah
people be like oh I [ __ ] I get it
what's going on I'm trying to get laid
well he's trying to get money instead of
being like ah yeah you know what I mean
yeah that's that's exactly what I do
every time that's it yeah
I auditioned for something in La this is
years ago and I was supposed to be it
was me and an old guy and I was reading
a script and we were watching a football
game as my dad and he dies next to me
right and they were like all right go
action and I was like oh look daddy
caught the he caught the touchdown and
he's like you know and I'm like
what's going on you're dying on me this
is crazy and they they were like get out
they just they weren't even they didn't
even think it was cute or anything they
said please leave you reacting to a real
emotional is is just pure comedy I know
what to do
they set me right out there
Santa Monica yeah Dad that was it that's
what the script said
yes that I could do a little
Honeymooners to the Moon
yeah Ralph Graham had those serious
moments yeah yeah because even though
he's being big and sometimes it's a
little too big for the most part he was
the you know they were talking about the
intention right I mean that's what it's
about yes
so instead of you know once you I'll
tell you the best advice Michael Caine I
read the Michael Kane acting book that
also helped Michael kind when you don't
know what you're doing well he said he
didn't do impressions you don't know
what you're doing
he said just think in your head this is
great advice I think because it takes up
it takes the self-consciousness away he
goes just think in your head if he goes
if you don't act he goes at least do
this much he goes think in your head I'm
angry right now so when you're in the
scene if I'm angry with you right now
I'm thinking I'm angry so even though
I'm not trying to do anything I'm not
thinking about oh the cameras am I good
am I do I know my lines I'm just like
I'm [ __ ] angry right now because if
you're happy just think I'm happy I'm I
love you right now I love you so
whatever else is going on I'm thinking I
love you in the back of my head and then
whatever's going on instead of thinking
hey am I conveying uh take the focus off
yeah that's good and it keeps the
self-consciousness away because you at
least you have that intention right and
Michael Caine's a [ __ ] Mona Lisa he
was in that yeah every time I see
Michael Kane or Jack Nicholson I'm like
I'm sick of these guys every [ __ ] and
by the end of the movie I'm like this
son of a [ __ ] is great enough they're
the best they're just great and her
sisters that we think of he's just
trying to [ __ ] his wife's sister
imagine that saying yeah
read this poem on on page 111. yes we've
all we've all thought about it so we do
songs
before that movie around probably when
that movie's already yeah
she read that poem and we were hanging
out with a bunch of people and she goes
it's obviously a powerful poem she goes
oh it was E Cummings she goes he could
Cummings on my back anytime
by the way Michael Kane and Alfie the
worst body of all time it was so easy to
have a be a male in the 60s you don't
have to work out at all yeah and you
were a sex symbol yeah yeah Andy was a
badass he didn't get Carter and [ __ ] he
just got to do it yeah
he's great and everything he's a great
actor yeah still going in the Batman
movies
yeah he's [ __ ] he's got to be up
there now Michael Kane but I read his
book it was good yeah he was a hunk
but that's the whole point he never
tries to you never see Michael Caine
overdoing it no
yeah and that's what I mean by not
trying if he was if he was in Mona Lisa
going let me tell you something whatever
the guy instead he's like so and so like
you can just see he's [ __ ] annoyed by
this guy working for him and he'll kill
it's in the the lines the wood every bit
of it you know he's a mob boss that does
the work you're annoyed right and if you
were annoyed and you were my boss people
would [ __ ] die you don't have to act
like hey I'll kill you that's yeah see I
would dress up fully as The Godfather
and do that you and so Patrice told me
to do this
we do Colin we do it uh peeves on this
podcast and you're like the king of pet
peeves you have so many you're so good
at observational jokes and like I like
peeps what I'm doing I mean we have a
ton but I mean I think you have so many
in your act I think one one of them I
always think about is a guy who's
stretching while you're venting about
something serious oh yeah yeah yeah you
have so many like what do you have any
recent peeves you have the other one
about the guy who's mad about something
so he starts yelling at you you know
he's like this [ __ ] guy can you
believe this [ __ ] guy
when they put you in there yeah yeah
yeah well the recent one
which I'll tell you right now but it's
been a while is the people who uh are so
sincere they're full of [ __ ] by which I
mean they're like hey how are you oh yes
yes hey how am I good yeah hey and it
just oh it just drives me crazy because
I know their motive they're not you know
totally totally once in a while they're
imitating people that are really like
that yeah so once in a while you run
into somebody something to see a person
whatever you know
but in general especially Showbiz when
somebody's that sincere I'm like whoa
I'm trying to keep a step away I totally
get it they have two hands around their
coffee mug
you know you're like my wife had a
miscarriage perfect
let's let's do lunch sometime yeah yeah
shake your hands with two hands yeah
it's so good to see you like we haven't
seen you in 10 years we never talk we
have nothing coming exactly yeah no I I
have a guy in my mind
I just don't like that the new the new
earnestness and the new sincerity it's
infuriating yeah I got one and it's not
as good as as these but it's happened
the whole trip and it drove me crazy the
people who can't tell you what time it
is they have to do math you go what time
is it they go quarter to seven and
you're like
6 45 6 45. right
is that is that right
6 45. right can't we just say 6 45
quarter to seven no confidence now wait
a minute I know it's insane yeah why is
that bad I'm just saying just tell me
the [ __ ] time you don't do that with
anything else in life you don't go uh
how far is uh Wisconsin uh it's uh 100
minus eight just tell me it's a [ __ ]
92 miles away who wants the exact number
yes yes it's absurd Behavior I mean this
is such a social Norm at this point I
didn't even yeah
I'm sliding in and seeing it from
another angle yeah which I like but at
the same time I don't think it's the
kind of thing that that is going to have
an emotional effect on anybody to think
you've gone stock raving I understand
the peeve I just yeah I don't it doesn't
bother me
no one except Mark just say that we
don't do that with anything else except
time that's why it bothers me how much
is that pizza the pizza's ten dollars
the one goes it's five and five just say
ten but it could be a quarter no you
mean it's uh it's it's no you wouldn't
have said it's true three quarters of
ten
minutes
wait nobody says hey it's ninety percent
of ten dollars
if it's 9.50
okay okay I'm just trying to help you
think I appreciate it this thing is
really in trouble
is really in trouble
attacking my peeps
I'm just saying it's it's weird because
you hear other numbers I just want the
exact number now you got me on eight
different numbers I think it comes from
analog watches
that makes sense look at it you have
quarter quarter quarters that's a good
point no but people said quarter seven
when I was little
but they they you're from the 40s man
I'm saying that there were there were no
analog garages
no that was analog In fairness to me in
my defense I don't know what analog
means the hands the hands oh that's it
analog yeah all these time I was like
two I was like that sounds too hard for
me to investigate what analog means and
it's just meant hands
well it goes to show I could have saved
myself a lot of trouble in life like
tiny would analog means
I gotta pee for you please please guy
who cuts you in line gets busted cutting
you and then acts like he wasn't cutting
you oh wait go ahead I'm in the coffee
shop this guy cuts me with his dog and I
just very calmly say oh you know I'm in
line and he goes yeah I just want it to
get comfortable and I was like
we're the only guys in the coffee shop
the guy goes oh who's next and the guy
just gives me one of these
oh
[ __ ] that you you're the problem yeah
you'll blame you you're trying to
reverse it on me and now he's trying to
be the good guy again
there you go he's like you're in a rush
it's like no I was here [ __ ] face
exactly he's giving you credit for
something that he didn't even do the
sarcastic one it [ __ ] you yeah how about
the side swindler I think Larry David
covered it but the guy who does the side
he stands next to you in line and then
just starts inching in I know what
you're doing the side get the back yeah
you have Colin has so many Peeves in his
act that's a good New York I mean it's a
New York style comedy I do have a lot of
peeps I just I have a list you know from
over the years in common but like I have
like 200 of these little things like
that well okay do you have a quarter
pass
190. ah [ __ ] see it's hard to do math
yeah I don't think I mean a quarter to
seven it's too common it's been around
before you were born I know Thompson
would be a peeve yeah it is interesting
though the way your mind works when you
think about that it's not that you're
saying the the subtraction is bothering
you yes try living with this thing I
couldn't I couldn't register with the
people I thought it was you were annoyed
that the guy was not confident in what
he was saying in the time I just tell me
the exact number it's just weird if it's
it's 8 15. don't say quarter past eight
because now I'm doing extra [ __ ] I'm
just saying it's an efficiency thing to
me come on
but except that it's been around for so
long it's really you know you're coming
in thanks well so is uh gay is not
getting married we changed that what
happened huh
I'm just saying like gays used to not be
able to get married and you go oh it's
been around for so long you gotta accept
it well maybe I'm changing that's what I
hate about every arguing today it's
people bring up anything like that and
you're like oh [ __ ] right they bring it
up they win automatically like I said it
used to be this I was like okay yeah you
gotta have some virtual yeah example
then you win Roe v Wade roll back yeah
ah [ __ ] right right is it a Roe v Wade
or is it a quarter past
the vagina
that's a mole pasta hair well the other
weird thing about Roe v Wade rolling
back is they did it when nobody even
gives it even the Christians weren't
celebrating nobody gave a [ __ ] yeah it
was so weird because everybody's like no
that's not even an argument anymore
right well you know what's weird about
uh conservatives and I just heard this
they're all about family values but all
the most divorces and most teen
pregnancies red States yeah fun fact
you have a new bit about the the parents
who leave the babies in the hot car they
always seem pro-life
they do I mean that's true yeah
you can at least crack the window that's
what my parents did crack the window
yeah he just did it he just he just did
a pet peeve which is you he laughed at
your joke and you go they do
oh yeah that is a pet peeve I did that
yeah yeah but I think a joke
no when people do that you go uh you go
whatever whatever and and they go yeah
no wait hold on you laugh at a joke and
they go no I'm serious and I'm like I
know it's still funny to me though but
what about this here's the real pet
peeve not that one or not this one it's
the one where somebody goes they say an
obvious joke and then it's not a
comedian it's usually just a regular
person and then you kind of polite live
and they go I'm not joking
right that's right right oh that's the
worst how about this one this drives me
[ __ ] crazy at a comedy show oh we
might have covered this but the guy goes
where you from and the guy in the front
row goes uh New Jersey whoa
you asked the guy a question he answered
it what is this he didn't do anything
wrong it's true I hate the crowd workout
he was nothing ready the guy who's like
he goes he goes anyone celebrating the
birthday he goes yeah he goes happy
birthday
if they did it for one they'll do it for
12.
just think a little bit ahead of time
or write a [ __ ] joke how about that
but or the guy who keeps asking
questions because he hasn't found any
gold yet well what do you like to do I'm
a construction worker oh yeah a lot of
two by fours yes yeah Hammer yes Nails
yes where's this going give me a bit get
somewhere
we can do this all day your new your new
hour is like it's so much about it's
great everything I've seen of it is
great by the way it's killer it's killer
you are like you do social commentary
the way like I love it where it's uh
it's just you you [ __ ] on everybody
right it's it's not pandry at all it's
just funny yeah right down the middle
hey guys I'm an equal opportunity
offender
but I mean uh I mean how do you feel
about this one right now like what
because you know I mean you do so many I
feel like I'm glad you guys aren't
coming till the 23rd because I feel like
it's it's close but I'm still you know I
mean I'm still playing around tinkering
yeah and it's like you know I mean how
much [ __ ] time you can take you can't
take only right yeah you don't have to
be like hey I really have this thing
it's like all right get to it [ __ ]
you know for a comic the only way to get
it done is you get that put that
pressure on you because we'll just
absolutely a year and and abs around and
that's that's the case like deadlines
but I feel like yeah I feel like
I I feel like it's the least social
commentary but in some ways that makes
it the most because you know how it is
now everybody's talking about everything
all the time right right so it's sort of
like you know you almost want to talk
about it by by being more General yeah
because specifics are covered all that
you know what I mean yeah and the other
problem with going to see your show is
you know all the ideas you have you
can't get in
but you know all the ideas you have when
you can't crack it and then you go see
your show and I'm like oh I had an idea
like that but I couldn't figure out
where to go with it and you nailed it so
I gotta drop it well you have to drop it
I mean it depends on you know nah dudes
I don't want to be similar no
yeah like uh what was the one I saw at
the Minetta theater the one on Minetta
remember we we talked story no no it's
after that New York Story on Netflix it
was the one on Netflix where you you had
the people on the stage yes that one was
amazing and you had eight bits in there
and I was like ah I gotta drop all these
oh [ __ ] so it was you covered everything
it was so good there's the uh there's no
there's more genders than political
parties right yeah
but it's so funny like even that was
like three or four years ago yeah if I
said that today people were like what
the [ __ ] kind of a thing is that to say
isn't that weird even I don't know I
think it's so great everything I think
it's great too I think there's little
things that happen that keep like
inching towards him true culture with
people like like it might hit just
slightly less hard now yeah people would
be like that's uh questionable and then
you go to that and you're like was it
worth doing this if it's not killing
right I know what you mean right yeah
you have to be killing but then you're
like that's a good Instinct that's what
makes you great is you're like am I
killing because but shouldn't you push
back a little no yet but you still want
to get let I'm saying of course if
you're not you guys both know one of the
biggest problems is people that don't
elicit laughter in Iraq uh obviously
you're an epidemic it seems like yeah
but you think it's a given every time I
do these interviews with like uh well on
the road and stuff with the whoever the
papers or whatever you know they're
always like so about like comedy came
back over first laughs like doctors
first Do no harm if you're not getting
laughs it's irrelevant everything else
don't advertise comedian right middle
ABS they don't talk about and then of
course the highest form may be you
saying what you really want to say sure
but if you're not getting laughs it's
all I don't want to talk about it's not
even comedy it's not even comedy agreed
but boy has it gotten uh muddy these
days yeah you know it's gotten real
blurry I think like these critics get
obsessed with with Comics that don't
necessarily get to laugh because maybe
they think that's like something grander
or greater that's exactly there's an
arrogance to it whereas like I I have a
lot of love for Comics that are you know
bleeding on the road because it's I
agree it's they're you have four Hills
and yeah exactly it becomes this this
Romanticism of the kind of tortured
artist but it's like but laughter first
you know what I mean and laughter is
harder you know what and laughter I say
it in this I say it in the show now lamp
is a lie detector test oh that's a
[ __ ] thing it's a lie detector test
because it you're speaking some there's
something truthful going on that people
are suddenly involuntarily laughing yes
yes but that goes back to the point of
the the trans joke you're like can you
do it now I don't know but it's still
funny even if they're laughing less it's
a it's a less of a laugh because of this
nervousness not because the joke is
worse well yeah but you also have to you
know I mean you have to factor in all
that stuff but that's why it's like he's
right you do have to evolve to some some
sure or you are that stubborn guy right
but don't forget and ready to say blue
say what it said about evolving what was
that don't you remember the line I think
you actually retweeted it did I I said
people say if you're involved with your
audience I go that's why I came to
college
that's a great thing with Society
convention this is what I'm saying
that's why I'm saying but there is hint
of the evolving though don't you think
of course there's a hint you don't want
to be the old there's always a hint of
course but that's a [ __ ] brilliant
line but that's the point that's that's
comedy that line is comedy comedy became
like hey the audience will uh determine
your [ __ ] that that's what I'm saying
yeah when you guys said no we're not
funny I might as well go to the audience
and just sit around have a conversation
but to some degree we do have to focus
test all right this is like totally
right
I mean you also have to take them
somewhere you always have to take them
real place yeah it is it's a it's a well
those are my favorite jokes are yours or
someone like Chris Rock where like you
know you guys will kind of start a setup
sometimes we're like where's this going
and then by the end you're kind of like
oh [ __ ] like it's unpredictable so so to
that degree I totally agree that's yeah
of course I mean that's the thing and
yeah and just walk that line and then
yes and yeah and you do have to I mean
comedy Now does require somewhat of a
a lion taming and yes you have to tell
people hey hey hey hey hey let's live in
reality okay not that I no totally but
let's not you know how many times have
you said and say you're getting mad at
the thing you don't even understand the
joke it's just the word right
the subject matter just the words
they're like whoa whoa It's like stop
yeah get the point you don't [ __ ]
understand and then they laugh I know
it's the dumbest person ever the person
who just hears a word no but that's
that's a culture it's very common for
sure way more than it used to be used to
be about funny now it's about the lion
taming and the funny which is a whole
other element which we have to learn
almost a new skill to tap dances
Seinfeld so don't have that skill and
they become irrelevant so interesting
but those comments that don't have that
skill to kind of navigate you know yeah
it becomes Thoughtless and and you've
seen that comic kind of lose touch with
you sure so you have to have a hint of
that for sure of course but then is the
other side of the comics that are
literally
speaking in preambles on each joke
explain to people here's how I feel it's
like okay that loses something too it's
the Seinfeld episode The Gay not that
there's anything wrong with that right
is that it's that episode that they do
with every bit no for sure well David
tell goes he always says uh I was at a
gay wedding are you okay is everybody
okay I love that because I'm like yes
that's you gotta it's like you said you
gotta tame him it's you got a chair and
a whip up there if you have an audience
that comes to see you chances are they
know you're not a [ __ ] sociopath so
you don't need to explain yourself just
tell the [ __ ] beauty of it when you
go to the comedy club where you're doing
a showcase
yeah yeah because all it takes is a
couple of people and then you end up
getting too mad at them you know what I
mean like right right what the [ __ ] and
then the whole crowd's like hey you know
you're being kind of harsh and because
they didn't under they might not even
have heard or they don't understand how
much the intent of what this is yes has
been building up exactly getting back to
these people and the crowd's like whoa
let's take it down wow you saw me the
view the other night I was having a
solid set and I got off and I was like
hey all right you were like you sound
like you hated them and I was like yeah
I was pissed because one joke got a
groan right you got mad I mentioned you
got mad at them or something yeah yeah
you can't yeah perspective for them too
you know I know sometimes a comical open
with a joke that I'm like you just
shouldn't be opening that's true right
now you're married the whole [ __ ]
said yeah well Larry David you mentioned
Larry David was famous because he would
come out and do like a joke that was
just and then just shut down and yeah
because of the joke which I kind of get
did you see them in the clubs in the 80s
yeah what was it like it was you know he
was always he was always funny like you
know like like nobody was like oh this
guy's not funny no comedians everybody
respected him because he was funny but
he was just like I said he would just
turn too quickly yeah he would turn on
the crowd it you have to entertain they
didn't understand that you know it must
be frustrating to know you're funny and
not be doing well well there's a lot of
comments feel that way but he like if
you're funny and you're validated by
your peers and your bombing that's Gotta
Be You gotta be like what the [ __ ] is
happening well he was too cool to
perform he wouldn't perform because you
we all have that anger and you have to
keep performing right it is a show but
he wasn't willing to do that fake part
oh I remember the first late nights that
I ever did the opening joke had like six
punch lines and it didn't get near to
what I wanted and the next four minutes
was me faking a smile exactly the best
acting I've ever done you probably
killed the next one I did fine oh okay
but I was I had to what am I gonna what
am I gonna go [ __ ] you you have to power
through yeah but that's that's Showbiz
yeah well I mean it is interesting I
mean but but that is the only beauty is
that like at least it's reality in the
sense that all this talk like a lot I
feel like a lot of jobs and Showplace
they can talk like this and then just
talk about the rest of their life all
three of us have to go in front of
people yeah tonight tomorrow next week
next month next year and live in reality
yeah so all the speculation is fine but
we still have to live in the real world
and go oh [ __ ] I forgot about that part
and so it's kind of cool that we can't
live in the uh you know this kind of
hype you know conversational like yeah
theoretical thing we still have to live
in the world which is keeps it keeps us
honest it does it does but it's also why
not everybody can do it yeah because
it's so harsh
you can just die comedy is Harsh I
always get jealous of musicians because
they just get up there and even if
they're doing terrible you can't nobody
in that audience can play that music
right but if we get up if I'm bombing
I'm getting no laughs everything in that
audience could do what I'm doing right
now standing on stage and not get any
lessons
you could change one word and half of
that and it would kill yeah but you got
to figure the reason when you're one
[ __ ] word away I know and it might be
one syllable I know but when you find it
if you if you think starting to go south
and you start stuttering and all these
jokes it would work if you didn't
stutter like yes picked up every little
stutter yeah yeah you kill the momentum
and you you [ __ ] up the setup and you're
like well that's not gonna hit next oh
why am I but I'm gonna still do it and
you're like I knew that one hit yeah
that's why I don't do stories because
I'm worried that I'll flub one thing
along the way in the six minute tail and
then you know it'll ruin the whole thing
but you can't get out of a story you
gotta do that you would do the funniest
thing on tough crowd you would keep in
jokes that didn't work sometimes because
I've never seen a late night host do
that right but you keeping a joke and
after a joke when work you just feel
like yeah I knew that one wasn't gonna
be good you would just say that on the
show I wrote all the monologues myself
that's insane that was my thing I was
like I'm writing all the monologues
that's insane myself like I was just
like that yeah every day I could do this
[ __ ] and so a lot of them were like not
that strong but something was wrong but
um yeah well we keep jokes and the bet
the proudest thing about tough guy when
I look back at now is the fact that if
somebody tried to Pander to the crowd we
go stop yes go ahead
um hey folks they they're good people
all right give them Applause yeah it
would just be brutal but we do that dude
they do it to me too but whoever it was
done to it was just oh what you never
saw on TV you never see it on Tuesday
today that's shaking now than it was
then it is what's that about I don't
know
[Laughter]
I mean seriously go see Colin's show I
mean it's just like it is every part
I've seen has been killer so far all the
shows are killer we Mark and I huge copy
how Colin and Mattel and and the great
New York Comics you know try to build
material Colin does I'll work out the
fat black at the uh at the cellar to
work out wheat Mark and I do that you
guys are great because you you do the
work that's why you always have new
great material because it's it's not
rocket science it's horrible right
humbling work yes well you have the best
line you say a lot of people don't want
to write because riding proves you're
not a genius yeah because you know you
go I'll figure out up there but when you
write you sit and stare at a page and
it's brutal you have to confront your
own mediocrity yeah damn and that's
beautiful you know it's horrible right I
want to be a genius but guess what I'll
write something I'm like oh my God you
know what I mean my aunt would have said
that it was my um nothing has my hand
she's actually very
um what I'm saying I know I picked the
example like a soccer mom type sure but
yeah I'm just saying that's sometimes
you write oh I can't believe how corny I
am I know but the beautiful thing is we
get to show people the ones that worked
yeah you know on TV yeah well hopefully
who knows
by speaking of pet peeves I hate
with a passion that your generation I
hated the generations before but I hate
even more with your generation more
certainly all about podcasts and YouTube
and all the stuff that you guys still
are so obsessed with like I have a
Tonight Show set it's been it's been
making me Furious for years and years it
may be mad when people do the for
Letterman sets and now it makes me it's
baffling why isn't that fun it's fun to
go on TV and do a set yeah because it's
you guys are you know that's not gonna
affect your career the way you any other
YouTube or anything works now yeah
you're right but it was five years ago
nobody's is that 1978 when a Tonight
Show meant I did a set at the night by
the way David Brennan in those days it
really did yeah David Brenner they said
the first one was on tonight's show he
said he was broken or something he had
like 80 bucks in the back the next thing
you got seventy thousand dollars worth
of work wow back when that was like a
lot of money sure the next day I go in
Fallon now I lose followers Yeah well
yeah it's true
tonight's show said I'm like oh I get so
irritated but I've been irritated just
let him in for that it gives you a
little something on the just something
to put on a flyer and dumb audiences in
uh in the middle of the country guys
tonight show they do people people were
like oh wow people get excited about
that [ __ ] still no comedians get excited
it's driving me nuts I'm giving you one
it's definitely dead now it's pointless
now and if you tell one of those guys
that's the problem oh yeah well I'll
tell you what even back in the old days
I used to work in this the I mean the
late 80s I'd be working with somebody
who did like three lettermans and I'd
have to be the headliner ah and I was
like oh that's enough this guy did three
lettermans nobody cared that was in the
80s this is all a delusion people right
right well back then when we didn't have
all this kind of promotion so if you
went on Letterman and promoted I'm gonna
be at hilarities next week they no would
barely do a bob ass canning Club but if
you did local radio in Cleveland you
would sell tickets right so it's all
delusion yeah but you get to show your
mom
yeah my mom moms don't give a dab
they're not comedy nerds they don't give
a [ __ ] she's not a comedy nerd but she
like she'll be like oh that's a thing I
can see it's tangible like if you want I
was on Good Morning America the third
hour by the way this morning and which
one you didn't get those those hot uh
anchors who are hooking up oh yeah
I did it with them once they were great
they seemed great they were great but
anyway they but I'm just saying that's
gonna affect people's moms more than you
know uh that's true that's true
Letterman if you do like Good Morning
America like you know Rachel Ray and
stuff that that seems like it's more
Ellen I refuse to give up on this one
I'm I'm dying on this hill now I see
what you're saying it doesn't bump that
move the needle but it gives you little
things you don't want a club promoter
says what do you got you can send them
that link and they see in a suit
laughing yeah you're right though it
doesn't move the needle but this helped
us headline when we were younger that's
true yeah it really did because club
Owners were living in the 80s and like
he's been on Kona and then like wait why
is this guy selling any tickets so yeah
it helped us get work so I think we're
on some level still locked in that but I
hate the fact that even my generation
was locked in when I had a guy that did
three Letterman's actually now I realize
he did two lettermans I don't know why I
said three but anyways it was a bit of a
badge of honor you know I think I was
trying to win the argument I get it hey
you gotta fight I gave myself the people
of mine people lying to win argument
there's two what are you Santos
yeah I don't know I won't do one now
probably because they tweaked my act so
much and he's such a headache they're
like write it out in text I'm like oh
[ __ ] you yeah I know I know but let's
write I'd like to write right now not a
bit I'd like to write what are the
bullet points Mark needs to hit to save
his marriage when he goes home
that I need help with
number one is listen I didn't even want
to do this goddamn podcast but I feel
like it sells tickets
that's not bad I'll use that actually
tonight
we're talking about the house
you didn't go this is she must on some
level realize how big it is for you to
take this amount of time off though well
I kept yeah and I kept saying Quinn
Quinn she's like oh okay I wasn't lying
he was excited as hell yes I'm a fan
that's why I said we should do it next
week if I knew you were coming back in
the list from South Africa I've been
there coach
he's gonna sleep like a beast I hope you
don't have a gig tomorrow or tonight I
gotta I'm flying out to Nashville
tomorrow 10 sold out shows you better go
to sleep early today I got a couple 10
shows is a lot yeah I don't know I'm
diving right back in because I got that
uh vacation rust yes and you got some
vacation jokes I do I just have some
stuff on yeah
[Laughter]
how done is it is this say you're at
like 85 I would say or quarter past 75
50. 75. 75 that's not close at all right
and you know what really put this over
the top is if you did a Fallon
appearance I think I did Fallon last
week did you oh I thought it was no big
deal one of these Comics still do it
tonight
I personally love Fallon he's a nice guy
it's some of my favorite
TV to do it because we bust each other's
balls and we go back a long way and uh
and it's a guaranteed laugh yeah but I
just meant as far as I didn't mean
felony I mean any of these talk show
appearances here's what bothers me about
them let me just rephrase it okay it's
not doing them it's the fact that it's
his ritual Now set up and it started
back then where everybody is being a
comedian being funny and then suddenly
it's like let's make sure we tensely
wear a nicest suit and it's like
watching a criminal in court right
they're like this
um okay and then okay let's wait and it
just it takes all the fun out of comedy
and the edge yeah totally they make you
less of you I I agree with that yes and
then it's all this Precision [ __ ] and
it's always precise we this joke and
then one minute before you go on lose a
minute you're like wait a minute
to the T and they tell me lose a minute
yeah we're late on time or stretch two
minutes all right all this precise
things yeah and now this that maybe
that's what a Sam Kinison Letterman is
so epic it's so goddamn epic because he
really just breaks all the rules he goes
in the crowd he [ __ ] with a guy he
yells he goes long so I mean that was a
career maker that was I don't know if
that did make his career I'm trying to
remember at the time I bet the
Dangerfield thing helped that the
Dangerfield thing was big back then that
show was big and that felt like real
comedy it felt like it was in a club and
it was dude Rodney Rodney bringing
people out and the intro's being funny
for Bill Hicks this next comic he's so
far ahead of his time his parents
haven't even met yet
that's killer he wrote a joke about the
comic he's presenting that's pretty
great yeah those were great sets Robert
Shimon oh they were great killer yeah
even dice dice hilarious apparently for
everyone everyone on those lineups yeah
yeah they were all funny and Rodney was
great yeah Bob Nelson Robert Townsend he
turned me down
um Rodney he told me but he turned me
down flatteringly he goes hey kid it's
hilarious I can't put you on for that
kind you know you're like an inside guy
for Comedia you're not I'm just like you
look great yeah don't worry video I
can't put you on wow then we came up and
said at least he complimented you that
at least he said it to my face yeah he
didn't call my manager he said it right
after the sentiment you're going great
kid you're great you know I can't put
you on wow that's pretty insane though
at that level to do it that way yeah she
did it directly yeah he's a comedian
that's unheard of were you a huge Rodney
fan yeah I mean it's so funny so funny
now what about the what did Dennis
Miller tell you because I think about
this oh Dennis he goes yeah he came to
see I mean this was a big deal back then
he was the guy you see me he was the guy
and he came to see me with his date and
he goes I mean so it was already like
that's the honor this guy came out of
his way that's insane he watched me do
an hour and he goes you're great man
you're great you got it all he goes
there's just I can't put my finger on
there's something missing
[Laughter]
[Music]
well
you found the one man's yeah maybe
that's you um the one-man show is now
they're on Netflix right of course I
mean the the New York one is like the
New York City is like the New York once
in a while especially for his kids from
these New York hit you know not just in
New York not just for New Yorkers it's
an incredible show yeah a show that's
what it does that is like that is that
is like in the top New York things for
me ever I love it thank you I don't know
that was my uh that was the one I could
die with in fact I did have a heart
attack uh after I did that and in the
ambulance when I thought I was dead I go
well at least I get the New York story
out there wow
so just it just thought it was my story
I wanted it out there like what I
thought what I think the world how the
world
you know that's part of our thing when
you're doing stand-up you're going you
know you want laughs but you also like
saying hey here's how I see the world
yes you want people to laugh like okay
good
I have a question about One Man shows
for you is you know I don't think a lot
of one-man show Comics work out their
show in a comedy club yeah yeah you
might be one of the few who has that I
mean it's always some queefy black box
or something well that's why I hate even
calling it a one-man show because I feel
like it's such a uh negative connotation
to us sure that's the rest of the world
I mean but um yeah no that's exactly
right I love I mean if it works at clubs
but it is funny because you do develop
uh like a harsh like a shell where like
sometimes if I'm in the theater I'll be
like I'm gonna get to the next show
quick because it's too quiet some
asshole's gonna say something right I'm
gonna have to [ __ ] you know stop for
a minute and bust his but like you know
you're always ready yeah because that's
comedy exactly I mean you stick laugh
out loud whatever it's called in Phoenix
about a month and a half ago you know oh
yeah and it was going great and then
three quarters of the way some guy goes
in the middle of the show so of course I
attacked him I really laughed and I go
uh well we just make a joke and a girl
goes right after so now it was funny
performing now this old man uh what the
[ __ ] I turned on her yeah and it's like
only come in the middle of a great show
and I'm like stop doing that because
you're gonna get back to the crowd yeah
you know what I mean but you could just
tell I was like I busted his balls but I
should have just kept going with her
yeah instead I just got so irritated
that she added it what if I went back
into another bed of course because and
she's not with him right she's just
drunk too and then you just you know I
mean so that's the difference you always
have that side of you for better and For
Worse yep at a one-man show where I'm in
a theater but I'm just thinking you know
I mean like watch out for somebody you
know I mean yeah you never fully trust
completely I'm jealous of those Comics
who can just take a beat and look around
I'm like oh what kind of confidence do
you have unbelievable isn't that wild
I'm joking joke just cause I'm terrified
of losing this it's unbelie and those
that is a real skill real skill really
important I don't have a I don't think
of it but it's a real skill the wireless
tons of comics suck though a lot of them
suck but the good ones it's impressive
it is impressive when you can when you
can chill in the silence and then like
release that tension get a huge pop that
is pretty damn cool but yeah but a lot
of those Comics I'm watching who are
comfortable in the silence I'm like you
shouldn't be that comfortable no that's
right yeah that's true that's right but
I wish I had a little of it wouldn't you
like to have a little yes a little no
I'm with you man I I everywhere I [ __ ]
up one word I panic no exactly frazzled
no they really they there's there's
things you can take from all these other
Comics yeah like that that kind of thing
where it's really like that's something
you should learn that's I do regret not
having that because that's a real you
know yes I would have wrote as my I
wouldn't have written as much and I
wouldn't be developing but but you could
still do that you still have a work
ethic and still have that you in fact
you should give yourself that gift
because
you know you're doing all this hard work
you know what I mean and then just and
the crowd it even relaxes them to a
certain extent I know they like it too
yeah because if I'm so that I think they
get like lulled almost into this this
kind of like I can stop listening
because he'll just keep going right but
if you pause they listen more but
because if you pause you're saying hey
guess what this is important uh I'm
giving you a joke well I just always say
Cosby bad example but Bill Cosby he's
gonna put you asleep
less jokes than any kind of comedian I
know I never even like this act but but
the way he structured it every time he
did a joke we got a reward in the middle
of the story right right so he wrote One
20 of the jokes you guys have written
but it was a reward and that's how that
those people structured they put a
reward in the drink too for himself
but uh yeah he uh he would do like three
hours and he would yeah but I'm saying
there's one three hours of jokes yeah
that's a good point and people loved it
even comedians loved it and yeah because
it was the the structure was set up so
he was like I'll get you the joke but
you're in the story like oh yeah I mean
it's like a nice restaurant where you
don't mind the food taking a little
longer because you know it's going to be
you know spectacular that's true but
there is something about the New York
Pace where your father got the seller
who's like machine gunning you've heard
that right he's machine gunning jokes
and it's hard to go up there and just be
like what else but some people do people
do it very successfully even in that
yeah even in that uh thing yeah I've
seen Bugatti go after like some high
energy black comic and he goes hey
everybody and he gets them I'm like how
did you do that and you know who used to
do that Ray Romano uh yeah they used to
call him the Bugatti
would go up after like a killer show
yeah at the cellar like you know what I
mean and everybody just killed
two kids still young people uh my wife
and people like what the [ __ ] he's too
much kids and in three five minutes he
just get him and kill wow he's just kept
his energy you know yeah now he a joke
joke it was a different sub it was still
in his like Bugatti in his uh body you
know just like yeah here's the way it's
got to be and as you both know the real
the first thing in comedy that takes the
hardest to learn is I'm all you've got
folks this is all you've got nobody else
is coming I can't be what I'm not
um same with acting yeah I can't be
something I can't be whatever comic you
love I'm not that person all I have is
me that's all you got um so it's either
enough or not but nobody's nothing's
coming out of here but but this person
and that's I feel like that's the thing
a lot of Comics that's the that's the
step that takes a few years right when
you're just like this is it folks this
is all I'm bringing I can't bring energy
this is not my energy it's weird because
you do the road to connect and to make
your [ __ ] tight but then when you do
some of those bad Road rooms as you said
you're used to the woo and that makes
you a little more guarded to slow down
like how many absolutely how many of
those shows have you done where you're
like I have to speed up my set because
they're [ __ ] talking of course well
yeah most I mean that's when you have to
yeah yeah I mean that's the only good
part is like you said when you work them
it's I mean it's it's 50 50 it's going
to go great or they're going to get
thrown out but sometimes you get great
rewards when you're just like hey you
know you stop that conversation and
bring it in sometimes you get some good
things out of that you know what I mean
yeah but the worst part is in the middle
of that thing you know I mean because if
you're not tense with those people it's
less tense if you're like hey what the
[ __ ] then it gets tense right but the
worst part is the people trying to
defend you and then start to fight with
another team the other day it was like
shut the [ __ ] up you're like no I can
handle this but it's too late right yeah
it's terrible what do you think of those
guys who will do stand up for years be
great at it and then just kind of fizzle
out and then do a maybe a movie here and
there or something
I wouldn't you miss it you know these
people just kind of stopped doing it but
do they really stop I mean I feel like
everybody goes back to it I think a lot
of people go back because they have to
they're like I need some income no not
Kevin James Ray Romano saying how many
of them they all go back they miss it
there's something about the live the
live show that yeah it's honest yeah
yeah you're talking about maybe Steve
Martin and Eddie Murphy or the two oh
yeah they have perfect examples but they
didn't fizzle out they didn't fizzle out
but they don't really do something
Letterman what the hell Letterman but he
was he only did crowd work I think from
what I heard about him oh he had bits oh
because it's a crowd guy because
everybody blows Letterman but I'm a Leno
guy
um because he's as a guy I don't know I
don't know if you want to talk talk
shows the Letterman's talk show is
better but as a guy I like Leno yeah I
mean as a guy yeah I don't really know
like as a stand-up he seems like a
better stand up oh yeah you better hang
better stand up still doing it better
say he was great at saying I mean he'd
go on Letterman and just do these great
bits ahead of his time you know oh yeah
yeah God you bet everybody what's that
you met everybody yeah
and half of them are dead yeah that's
the the sad part yeah I'm glad you're
okay man I'm glad yes
serious I went to my you know I'm like I
really have a diet that's where really a
bit it's like throwing down it's like
yeah I mean it's 12 year old kid died
sure a lot I went to my doctor who's a
very serious strict doctor Orthodox and
about a month ago but I take my
medication this is how good statins are
my diet is not I did the stress test he
goes whatever you're doing keep doing it
uh he said you're in great shape that's
how good statins are they're the miracle
drug what's a stat yes I well if you're
old you know all this stuff you guys oh
sorry sorry I don't know anybody over 50
seconds I start and stats that's all
you're talking about is that a pill yeah
oh okay oh there it is all right
it's the miracle drug of all time really
whoever invented Statin should be as
rich as as Bill Gates now are you are
you cutting back on the uh bad food are
you working out yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh really was because I wasn't taking a
stat and I hate to keep saying the word
Statin but you know if it saves one of
your listeners
it's a miracle drive but you wouldn't
good you were in your bedroom
Japanese guy ah he invented it wow okay
does that freak you out that you're in
your the best shape of your life and
you're and you have a heart attack
I mean at the time it did it it
depressed me yeah
well obviously but it was it how painful
was the heart attack painful I couldn't
believe how much pain it is I literally
thought you went numb whoa you know they
would say your left arm goes numb my I
was in so much pain I was curved that's
what I do when I act about cursing
because you feel like a like somebody's
pushing their elbow their fist into your
chest and it doesn't stop I was going
crazy it just really hurts that's
[ __ ] how long does it last it kept
like it had to be an hour until it was
funny in the operation oh my God it's
like that Richard Pryor joke shouldn't
have all that sport
okay but yeah he had one of the great
one of the greatest bits was that uh was
that bad about his uh oh yeah
all his medical stuff was really funny
yeah he would personify everything you
know the heart the heart would talk yes
crack pipe would talk but yeah yeah he
was really uh yeah yeah that's been
covered yeah it has but he's good he's
good he's a good good comic yeah
did you ever see him go up or no live no
I met him at once briefly for two
seconds yeah I don't want to keep you
too long I know you gotta oh yeah I got
a big important show what were you going
after this I gotta go I gotta into
somebody wants to like the New York is
doing a piece you're not doing James
Corden you're doing five oh you gotta do
a late night James coordinate Balthazar
you still got it
good but it's still there it still works
still works so I still want to hear I
still am interested she went on the
Safari first you went at a hotel in Cape
Town for a couple of days yeah I do the
beach and a little NightLight where'd
you go
we stayed no we stayed in a five-star
hotel it's Rand out there that's the
name of their money Rand and it's so
cheap like that pizza would be 8 million
Rand so you live like a king I stayed in
these great hotels and uh we'd go on
these tours and we saw ostrich and
penguin and baboons did you go to that
ocean where the ocean meets yes I did
all that stuff I got some photos of that
also so weird because there's just you
go to this ocean thing I never felt like
this in my life how are you feeling in
parts of Africa they always go oh it's
where like life and you just get this
weird feeling right yeah yeah strange
Vibe it's weird and
we had this old driver lady and she was
sweet as hell but she's so boring you
know like as a comic you're like you
gotta bring it sister give me some fun
facts so I kept being like give me some
apartheid stuff right she was like well
that's a little heavy and I'm like you
mean you're talking about a palm tree I
don't care about the species of plant
give me the racism but she wouldn't do
it well did you go to Belfast I was in
Belfast this summer and they have
ex IRA and UDF fighter guys that that
give you toys now now we're talking
that's the kind of thing you would like
that's what I want I want a holocaust
museum I want a 911 memorial I want the
the juice it's interesting only we had
the we had the woman but she was still
interested
in fight with the IRA I see her family
was I arranged you know it wasn't the
one you weren't the guy that was in the
actual we were all in Ireland together
remember oh the greatest I still
remember us being in that Museum and
Krista Stefano farted and we all started
laughing and everyone just stared at us
like you guys are [ __ ] Americans and
even that museum it was all English yeah
there was no Irish Museum yeah yeah
that's fun we would meet up at about 10
have breakfast and be like we're gonna
go to the Bluffs then we're gonna go to
the museum then we'll go to the the
brewery and we'd never we'd stay there
for nine hours in time only one person
made the most out of that trip and
golfed every day went all over the
country Nate brigazzi you went to the
same Cafe every day we were there yeah
yeah you're such a New Yorker you find
your spot and you're like I'm I'm set
Ting I was like what the hell is he
doing going out there golfing he'd go at
six a.m yeah yeah I remember we were
sitting there with Chris D and he just
got a sitcom or some pilot or something
and he was telling you about it and you
go that's not gonna go and he was like
dude we got chess voluntary we got NBC
it's all locked in they go up you're
like I'm telling you it's not I'm gonna
go and it didn't go because I read it Ah
that's that stuff they
it was everything that's wrong I mean
everything that's wrong with
you know Showbiz the creative thing
today oh yeah everything about it I was
like there's no it's not fun it's not
funny it's resolved it's all imaginary
world yeah she's so laugh track no no
just the writing the characters are
imaginary uh
damn well he's doing fine now Christy
funny guy Christy but yeah that that see
that first I don't feel like I don't
know if they would have us back
what I don't think that the Vodafone I
don't think they would have us back why
not no I don't know I think it was fine
but nobody cares right look we all did
great but they don't what we we didn't
it was no reason to bring us back I was
clamoring for us sure well you you yeah
you're a big deal there yeah Quinn come
on I thought I would be but yeah you
watched her show you're a [ __ ] name
for me back well I remember we saw Tommy
Tiernan yeah boy did he [ __ ] well it
was like 600 seats yes murdering
murdering he'd take his cap up put it on
the mic stand and just zero to 60.
that was great I bombed a few times
because I had to learn the rhythm of it
it's a different Rhythm over there right
it's a it's a serious uh you know it's
so funny because I think you said it
actually that even though they drinking
so somebody shows at 9 31-10 and they
drink it so we all know what that Vibe
is yes only the difference is here
they're listening after each joke
right no momentum no you just joked a
joke no momentum so you it's a joke haha
okay what do you got yeah yeah even
though they're drinking it's deceptive
drinking totally the energy is not gonna
be like hysteria tight drinkers yes yeah
they're just listening yeah it's really
interesting right they're a great people
you see the movie Belfast yeah I did
yeah it was good it was cute it was a
good movie horrendous literally they
really softened the IRS
I like Kenneth Brown but I just I was
like Jesus Christ
they was Disney fired yeah you know a
movie I just watched on my flight back
like classic I've never seen but [ __ ]
amazing Paper Moon oh I've never seen
dude it's great looking amazing
great move and all the griffs are
brilliant like no one ever pointed out
how great these people on the grips it
wasn't about the grips if they made that
now it would be all about the grips yeah
yes and they wouldn't be as clever yes
but uh that's true I mean dude she's
amazing she's great it was like I've
never seen a kid act like that I was a
little I was about her age when I came
out I was mad I was so in love with her
for years oh yeah thought about it for
like two years that's all I can think
about it was a perfect age yeah no well
I mean but um and Madeline Khan was
hilarious oh she's underrated she was
great she's always funny Young
Frankenstein right like oh my God how
good was she in uh you know Blazing
Saddles yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah so she was
hilarious is it true yeah what a nice
guy
she was great in the movie clue too
she was yeah by the way you know it's a
bad movie speaking of Khloe that new uh
onion movie oh you didn't like onions I
didn't hate it you hated it I saw you
know what happened I saw it in Fort
Wayne Indiana that theater so I think
that really I was kind of like thank God
I watched movies on a plane and I'm like
this is a great one yeah tell people
like hey what's so good about it I
didn't hate it I mean it's just it was
just it was fun it was bad the only good
thing about it was well first of all
that movie was jerking itself off the
whole time I was so proud of himself but
you were it was Christmas and I'm with
my wife's family so I'm like put this on
and it kind of saved it because it's
just so awkward
so you just put this movie on and we're
all like all right did you like the
first one or no yeah it was okay I mean
he did the best he could but he's really
not right for that kind of a guy you
know I think you don't think he's good I
thought he's all right I like it but
that part you of all people he's playing
in New Orleans I do declare I mean it's
a bit of a black face on the southern
accent yeah it's just that crazy you
know like he's doing a great job over
who he is but yeah he's not the guy for
that part you can't have a guy all
jacked up like that all right it's just
that right well he wants to get out of
bond so bad yeah I'm taking everything
and he's doing he's showing his range
but I don't need to you know what I mean
Ben what what have you seen that is good
recently oh you see Western Front no All
Quiet on the Western Front the original
no the new one no it's incredible it's
moved me I'd like to say it move me
Jerry so good I think it's up for some
awesome well what else is up
that was good that was really good I
know I gotta watch that
weird as [ __ ] I'll watch that yeah the
weird part I didn't like there was there
was one there was one thing in it that
kind of I was like this is insane yeah
but it's great it's a great oh I mean
the writing's so good like the dialogue
is so [ __ ] so good just uh it's
what's funnier than two friends and yeah
the beginning starts it's just two
friends they go out every day there's 10
people in town and this guy doesn't want
to hang out with them anymore
oh that's great so funny it's funny as
hell and it's like is it a spin-off of
uh In Bruges no no okay no but yeah no
no no no it takes place like uh 20s I
guess or something you know but uh yeah
man Colin Farrell's [ __ ] great in it
oh my God it's like tragic I know he's
so good yeah he's amazing
is that at all
I feel like he was in a ton of shitty
movies for like 10 years because he's
in the rise he goes he's got it all he's
got a little
yeah he really was good
um anything else he said that's good
um I don't really think of someone I
just rewatch sexy beast you ever seen
that we were talking about before you
got here
really the best
in the beginning
I used to come on stage with that song
it's just so cool I love it yeah it's
great yeah what's that guy's name Ben
King no no
yeah yeah that that's my ideal vacation
just laying an Italian Villa pool drunk
at like two yes Don yes done you're
doing it done
I try to show that who's the other guy
who's uh the other scary guy oh yeah Ian
um
that movie [ __ ] rules that movie's
great it's real style there's certain
movies that I can't not I can't see and
not think of Colin like Mean Streets is
like a college oh come on beat streets
is better than Goodfellas I'll argue it
right now I'm saying it right now maybe
but it's a little long Main Street No
Good Fellas it's about eight minutes too
long I don't like either of these tapes
I don't like that take I mean I love the
movie I'm just saying I don't like
either take here no I'll tell you it was
too long Scarface Scarface was This
brilliant movie and then selling this
whole montage you're like buying the
place I know they're trying to get it
all in but it's like you're covering too
much right right dual part two Godfather
you know yeah the Scarface had the best
character actors of all time well Mean
Streets Abraham and uh yeah I'll tell
you another thing that's gonna blow his
mind how come there's never been a great
character movie about
in New Orleans the closest thing to
Great Character movie New Orleans with
those characters we all know it what oh
the book no single movie I mean a movie
that actually closing to New Orleans you
gotta talk to the mic sorry I was just
think doing all these characters
JFK
huh John Candy Kevin Bacon Tommy Lee
Jones right Joe Pesci I mean these
people all New Orleans characters you
guys had not moved by this now listen I
haven't seen the movie I saw it as a kid
it's the best it's the movie itself is
good yeah but the characters are so
funny and so brilliant yeah yeah I gotta
rewatch Oliver Stone kick as a kid and I
think I was too young for like half of
them yeah
Salvador was amazing platoon obviously
Wall Street and JFK that's all you need
to see with him they won't let him make
another movie now unless it's uh
a gangster movies
got a like movie trouble now right isn't
there some weird thing happening why
it's like Marvel comic walking off the
set or something like that yeah pull it
up he walked up the set I think Oliver
Stone got a little queuing on me yeah
oh my God he's been trying to make this
for 40 years oh Will Smith maybe that's
the problem yeah old slapperoo and Ray
Rice
I heard Rock's got some great Will Smith
stuff fine oh I bet he does yeah
all right what are we reading on camera
here all right boys come on
I think it'll come out eventually
80s in New York it's crazy that like
apocalypse now so that just kind of like
ruined Coppola I mean I made a couple
movies after that but I feel like he
couldn't do you think that just [ __ ]
him up
um
yeah I don't know I don't know I mean
the old movies have that was stupid like
The Outsiders and all that [ __ ] I think
that's what [ __ ] up that was a hit
though not the not the not a pocket was
not The Outsiders and one from the heart
it's his fault making all his [ __ ]
movies after that
[Music]
um
yeah why would you make those movies why
paycheck I don't know
no he didn't need a paycheck he had a he
had a wine array ah I'll tell you he's
probably pissed because George Lucas
really made the money yeah oh yeah and
George Lucas made the oh boy he made the
real money well he got the merchandise
for stuff yes yes it's like Nicholson
with Batman he got all the money you got
a merch deal for the for Batman and I
can get a piece of every Batman movie
that's the kind of thing that that the
last of those was they're like that'll
never happen again never happen again
they're like we're not gonna let that
happen he got a piece of Batman yeah
that's insane especially because he had
nothing to do with any no DC Marvel
before that or after he was just like no
I just want a piece and then give it to
him that movie he got so much money he
made wolf
oh yes that was fun I remember when
Disney pissed on Yes we made her shoes
isn't it this Market is territory
[Laughter]
had some fun moments Nicholson movies
are kind of fun oh yeah what about Ben
Kingsley does that on the floor right do
you think yeah a little dominoes yeah
yeah Nicholson's always fun no matter
how bad even I watched It's Complicated
or whatever the [ __ ] he's in with that's
not him that's Uh something's got to
give something's got to give I watch
that because he's in it he's fun he's
fun I think what is he is he in the 90s
yet he's got to be 86. I give him one
more year don't [ __ ] stop I don't
want him to go I'm just saying we're not
doing Deadpool he's definitely close
though
have you seen him at the Lakers games oh
he looks like it have you seen the
Lakers at the Lakers games
nice
why go yeah I mean Duke I love uh I love
that he would still be Courtside with
town like the you know yes the two guys
Robert Town look at that holy [ __ ] he
looks like uh Susan Boyle
Jesus that was young that was years ago
oh that's when he's still sexy
holy hell I heard you guys used to close
your accent
that was a big insult when I was coming
up guys hold on let me uh the turn
around
in the army
oh that's fun bucket list yeah I don't
know if I mentioned on this on this but
underrated Nicholson movie The Last
Detail uh
banged a lot of porn stars Nicholson
Sandler
yeah yeah remember him and Angela
speaking of Sandler man uh grown-ups
what's that oh you gotta you got a j I
wish they would have had a couple of
more of my moves in there really yeah I
like that chocolate song uh everyone's a
winner great tune oh great but how about
the fact that we played every day it was
just so relaxing and fun hanging out
there that set all day for like two
months old comedians everybody's just
joking and shooting Hoops all day
waiting for the you know between shots I
mean what's more fun than that yeah
standing shooting around but the best
player by far the kid that played my son
in the movie it's like 10 years old he
had an outside shot it was crazy really
and all the extras are sitting on the
watching us so every time you miss oh
this kid he was this by the end of the
movie people just loved him really he
was the greatest wow I don't I never saw
the movie well it was a classic you
missed foreign
how fun is that I mean sailor is just
the best at like we'll go to Hawaii
we'll do yeah First Dates yeah I lived
there for a year that's how he is genius
everybody stays top everything and he
works basketball into the movies you
guys just yeah and he plays every break
at lunch he finds a court in place
that's his thing wow one day I'm like I
can't play it I'm seeing because he goes
get him sneakers and somebody shows up
with sneakers news think is best wow
that's amazing Kyrie fives yeah yes well
not those but yeah yeah it was crazy
that's amazing I heard that you guys
used to go like do the cellar yeah and
just walk to West 4th Street and play
till like five in the morning
um we probably did I don't I mean I I
remember playing late at night it was
fourth year and we used to play when do
right before tough crowd me Patrice and
all these guys big J yeah Big Jake and
hoop really I heard that big J so we go
and play at Chelsea by 10th Avenue in
like 5th uh 23rd Street 2nd Street 28th
Street that was caught and we play
everybody would go there and play little
Kev Kevin Hawk and hope oh I bet and big
J and Patrice would be against each
other they're the two centers and both
of them could really hope wow and big j
a little spin I still remember his his
spin game yeah yeah we all used to play
it was fun really fun big J and Latrice
one in the morning yeah you know what's
so sad about that is if you did that now
we'd all have to get content hold on let
me get Kev doing this good move but we'd
have to film it kind of bummed you don't
have any footage Ah that's a good point
no I feel like the memory was as long as
you can remember it it's fine there you
go it's it'd be kind of cool though for
you it would be cool but Jesus
he does the All-Star Weekend [ __ ] he did
a he I think he tied Draymond Green in a
three-point shooting I believe it he can
really play Berkeley that's the kid is
that him
that's him huh wow it kind of looks like
you who's that kid
is that him arrested oh he's playing for
Northwestern that's his [ __ ] [ __ ] he
believed in Northwestern oh that's why
kid had experience he was a little kid
that's him I don't know you tell us I
can't I don't I have to see him as a kid
to really understand
I guess so yeah but he really had a good
game yeah that looks like him in the
corner there oh he's a little guy he
played football yeah but he was really
good hoop yeah he was an athletes uh
yeah there he is that's him yeah that's
it little Quinn really good I mean he
was just heating up he was killing the
whole crowd because the crowd right you
know we're all shooting anytime you miss
this kid's blasting it the whole crowd's
cheering every day that must have been
fun as hell oh it was so much fun does
this kid know what he had he's playing
hoop with Sandler and all these guys
what is this a Make-a-Wish that's being
super shimmy what a life I know it's
great yeah all right I better get the
hell out of here we love you go see
Colin's showing us the Lucio lortel uh
theater right now it's uh I guarantee
you're gonna be happy when oh yeah yeah
one of the best periods seen parts of it
it's incredible I think some of you are
better Twitter chunk I don't want to
give anything away but it's unreal the
Law and Order chunk for me [ __ ]
unbelievably funny oh the podcast [ __ ]
oh yeah that's so good man killer check
it out tickets are moving let's watch
the website trees to happen I don't know
colinquinn.com probably
show.com rocket science you know folks
no offense we can't find that I don't
want it coming I don't need a mental
idiot all right and this episode will
come out in June so uh
Sunday oh even better zadies oh yeah I'm
back in the clubs I got a special taping
coming up so I'm really hitting the
clubs hard because I gotta tweak this
hour it's a it's a quarter past 80
percent done and I'm going to Hawaii
again which that won't help my ACT but
uh in the Miami Improv you really want
to run it through the mud go to Miami uh
that's when you're gonna have to speed
that set up for yeah exactly Spokane
Comedy Club all the hot rooms Skyline
and Appleton whoo baby comedy at the
Carlson laugh it up in Poughkeepsie you
go to markdomencomedy.com check it out
we'll see you know we're starting off
the tour New Orleans Austin uh Dallas
Tulsa uh St Louis Vegas Vancouver
Portland uh [ __ ] Seattle roll over
Salt Lake Huntington AC Royal Oak
Minneapolis Boston DC I'm all over
samrail.com shows I'll see you on the
road Wilbur and uh get your Bodega cat
whiskey.com Bodega catwhiskey.com beard
you got anything to plug
oh the only thing I gotta plug is that
uh I'm just going on a long trip at the
end of the month at the end of this
month so if anyone's out there in like
Malaysia Singapore wow whoa what are you
soul searching
what's going on out there
might be a like a little [ __ ]
got a new bartender here you have a
little you have a little bar back with
you
let me know and we're thinking about
doing a little America's Got Talent
style uh bartender off for his temporary
Replacements yeah if you're a bartender
and you think you got what it takes yes
get in here we'll sample your [ __ ] uh we
love you thanks for listening see the
great Colin Quinn and uh
stay safe yeah can I get another South
African delay
[Music]
I've had
a much person and Norman's talking [ __ ]
about the [ __ ] post and I get down in
the same way
[Music]
I was feeling dangerous
[Music]
good
I think
[Music]